je suis content incrimination physique
alan ball se dire c'est dégueulasse et
moi je dis stop
1 in the name of love nous sommes
évidemment très très heureux de vous
recevoir
tu m'étonnes
filmé à la lellouche à la lellouche
bouge pas bougez pas là lellouche
aimez-vous c'est tout à la besson avait
donc fait un travelling nous vîmes pas
j'en ai rien à fatras vyntra
travelling halak et chiche chat
un chat pliez les genoux pour voir
pardon plier les genoux plus bas et
comme un coucou line but imagine ce que
j'aurais fait 30 millions de dollars
déjà je me serais pas prise comme
maîtresse de cérémonie vraiment tu
parles je fais un texto comme ça on est
libéré après je vois là je vais mettre
un truc simple genre salut un sens c'est
flou rance fort et steve ce qui me
connaît pas au loup je suis tombé
excusez moi oh
excuse moi je suis tombé je suis
maladroit tu ne sais pas me parler c'est
pour vincent c'est ça non j'ai fini avec
vincent terminé je les ai eus on a
décidé de partir chacun de notre côté du
à gauche ou à droite et aux milieux
maintenant y'a et nous c'est bon c'est
bon
j'en veux
[Musique]
en amérique on a un amérique on a comme
tu le sais le tournage de la saison 3
oui va démarrer au ce texte
j'ai évidemment dit que tu ne peux pas
un test